bonjour nadine montbrun alors délégué
territorial au handicap pour la fonction
publique nous sommes dans le cadre de la
de la semaine pour l'emploi des
personnes handicapées
donc qui a commencé hier on va parler de
l'emploi des personnes handicapées dans
la fonction publique pour la fonction
publique et pour ça il existe un
organisme
alors on va parler un peu de la crau
nice mais un peu compliqué un cef ip hfp
bon une fois qu'on a dit ça donc le
fonds pour l'insertion des personnes
handicapées dans la fonction publique
qu'est ce que c'est à quoi ça sert en a
dénombré alors ce fonds existent déjà de
relève de la loi du 11 février 2005 qui
donne à tous les employeurs de la
fonction publique l'obligation d'avoir
un taux de 6 % de personnes en situation
de handicap dans leur effectif
quand le tour n'est pas atteint et bien
les employeurs ont une contribution à
payer cette contribution vient alimenter
une solution une amende
exactement comme tu as fait que
sous-tend fin donc été respectée
justement cela pourra pas respecter les
réponses et 6% et donc ces fonds sont
destinés à accompagner les personnes en
situation de handicap soit qui vont être
recrutés ou soit qui au cours de leur
vie professionnelle
on va vivre une situation de handicap et
également à développer des actions
auprès des employeurs pour renforcer
leur politique handicap
alors qui dit faux fonds pour
l'insertion des personnes handicapées
dit forcément du financement autrement
dit ceux fpf ip afp finance finance dz
individuel au cas par cas exactement
donc vous avez plusieurs formes
d'intervention donc les aides directes à
savoir bien une personne un agent de la
faune relevant de la fonction publique
qui a une déficience et qui doit être
compensée donc le film va accompagner
l'employeur on va financer les
techniques
un exemple des prothèses auditives par
exemple pour une personne qui a une
déficience auditive
une personne qui a un reclassement
professionnel suite à une maladie
invalidante ou un accident ou un
handicap moteur et bien le film va
financer toute la partie
d'accompagnement l'aménagement du bureau
ou encore les aides directement lié à la
personne quel est le lien entre ce fonds
pour l'insertion des personnes
handicapées dans la fonction publique et
la démarche andy pacte martinique en dit
pas quels outils d'animation du fph fp
qui a été initiée en 2014 donc c'est un
outil de proximité auprès des employeurs
dont qui a développé plusieurs axes un
axe d'animation un axe observe à trois
puisque nous avons réalisé un état des
lieux de la situation du handicap au
niveau du territoire est également un
site internet dont qui permet aux
employeurs d'avoir l'exhaustivité des
informations pour à combleux accompagner
leurs agents
nadine mont brun délégué territorial au
handicap pour la fonction publique on
rappelle quelles peuvent être les
bénéficiaires rapidement vous y avez
fait allusion mais bon donc ce sont des
agents de la fonction publique qui sont
qui ont une aire qu th
ce sera leur reconnaissance en qualité
de travailleur handicapé qui est
délivrée par la maison départementale
des personnes handicapées
donc c'est l'un des documents
nécessaires pour pouvoir solliciter le
fonds alors jusqu'à maintenant
le fip prenez en charge les personnes
qui étaient aptes avec restriction et
augmentation du médecin à partir du 1er
janvier 2007 nous avons mis en place un
nouveau catalogue des interventions avec
bien cette obligation alors pas pour
toutes les pathologies mais pour une
grande partie d'avoir cet hercule th1
d'accord donc ça concerne des victimes
d'accidents du travail ou de maladies
professionnelles
des titulaires d'une pension
d'invalidité enfin bon voilà faut être
connu porteur d'un handicap
dites moi il s'agit aussi au travers de
cette semaine pour l'emploi des
personnes handicapées de faire un bilan
d'étape alors ça marche ce fonds dit
nous un petit peu justement depuis qu'il
existe ce que vous avez pu faire
et puisqu'il reste encore à faire et que
vous pourriez mieux faire aussi alors
aujourd'hui bien nous avons une
progression du taux d'emploi martinique
puisque nous sommes à 5,32 poussant de
personnes en situation de handicap au
travail anses et de la faune sur bing
donc il ya une progression puisque en
2012 nous étions à 3,62 nous sommes
encore un peu en reste par rapport au
national puisque au niveau national le
taux d'emploi et de 5,17 donc nous avons
encore des progrès à faire mais il ya
des actions qui ont été entreprises au
travers de conventions avec certains
employeurs pour leur apporter des
financements pour justement développer
une véritable politique handicap sur
trois axes donc un volet recrutement un
volet maintien dans l'emploi pour les
personnes qui se retrouvent en situation
de handicap au cours de leur vie
professionnelle et enfin un volet sur la
sensibilisation et l'information des
acteurs
alors je disais mieux faire encore avant
que vous puissiez prolongée sur ça vous
dit les fonctions alors c'est ça
concerne les trois grandes fonctions
publiques la santé dans les hôpitaux
voilà en général les hôpitaux publics
la fonction publique territoriale donc
essentiellement les villes les
intercommunalités là et la collectivité
territoriale et puis et puis la fonction
publique d'état quoi exact voilà alors
donc mieux faire encore et vous visez
vous voulez mutualiser les meilleures
pratiques de recrutement et vous l'avez
dit il s'agit pas de recruter simplement
mais aussi de maintenir les personnes
dans l'emploi voilà parce que les aider
à s'adapter si c'est un handicap qui est
arrivé en cours de carrière ou à les
écouter c'est vrai que nous réalisons
des actions et pour pouvoir je parlais
tout à l'heure d'actions de
sensibilisation pour pouvoir amener les
personnes à se faire connaître
eh bien il faut les informer et il faut
casser l'image
qu'on a par rapport au handicap parce
que souvent les personnes pensent
associe le handicap à une déficience
motrice donc quelqu'un qui en fauteuil
quelqu'un qui aveugle en 80 % des
situations de handicap sont des
handicaps invisibles donc le la majeure
partie aux élèves de maladies
invalidantes
vous avez exemple une personne
diabétique et bien peut être reconnu en
qualité de travail handicapés nous avons
une maladie récurrente au niveau de la
race noire et la drépanocytose et bien
cette pathologie également pu relever
d'une situation dont vous parlez de
pathologies voilà peut être reconnu
comme un tournant fait de l'importance
de la personne fasse la démarche c'est à
dire qu'elle lie et bien au niveau du
médecin ensuite elle va faire la
démarche auprès de la maison
départementale
mais il ne faut pas qu'elle s'arrête là
parce que nous avons des quatre
personnes qui ont leur ai recruté h mais
qui ne la produisent pas l'employeur et
donc du coup ils ne peuvent pas
bénéficier d'un produit alors quoi il y
en a qui sont gênés il ya un tabou il ya
une masse ont parfois de la part de
certaines personnes qui pensent qu'on a
une image négative en fait de la
personne en situation de handicap la
personne elle-même pense qu'elle va être
mis en marge de la société à l'autre ce
n'est pas la réalité performante à cause
de de cette pathologie qui la touche de
cette maladie c'est ça par exemple on
sait pas tout à fait ça c'est plutôt le
regarder d autre qu elle pense qu'elle
va être mise à l'écart ou quels risques
sont son travail alors qu'en fait elles
restent en souffrance et que parfois
émue elle a du mal à assumer c'est son
activité à l'anc en étant accompagné en
ayant une adaptation de son poste de
travail elles pourraient être plus
productifs et plus épanouie et surtout
dans son milieu professionnel oui c'est
ce que je dis ça parce que il s'agit pas
évidemment de prendre en charge ces
personnes ces personnes
pour les conduire vers une voie de
sortie vers une voie de garage
évidemment c'est pas à pas du tout alors
pas lié à une déficience pas lié à une
situation de handicap n'enlève pas le
potentiel de la personne donc cette
personne a une déficience
il suffit de d'harmoniser et de lui
apporter d'aidé communiqué des
améliorations au niveau de son
environnement professionnel pour pouvoir
lui permettre de fonctionner et nous
nous rendons compte que les personnes
qui ont pu être bénéficier d'un
accompagnement et bien elles sont plus
épargnés au travail et elles vont avoir
peu d'absentéisme à part si bien à un
moment donné elles ont une aggravation
leur pathologie
mais ces personnes sont dynamiques et
veulent justement bien comment je vais
dire travailler parce que l on us être
reconnaissants de leur employeur et de
leurs collègues
il nous reste une minutes d'interview
nadine mont brun délégué territorial au
handicap pour la fonction publique en en
martinique
d'ailleurs sur ces maladies invalidantes
il ya un séminaire qui a lieu ce matin
donc à la collectivité territoriale
enfin l'hôtel delà de la ctm un plateau
roy à cluny
voilà c'est entre 8h et 13h vous parlez
également de handicap psychique
exactement nous avons plusieurs
manifestations dans tout au long de
cette semaine comme vous l'avez dit dans
ce matin à 8h à la ctm pour tous qui va
concerner et bien le handicap est
visible avec des ateliers
nous avons également jeudi à l'ancienne
aérogare du lamentin une conférence
débat regroupant employeurs privés et
publics autour de la thématique du
handicap psychique et tout au long de la
semaine le handicap psychique rapidement
quelques secondes pour conclure alors le
handicap psychique et bien c'est parfois
une pathologie qu'on n'identifie pas
forcément d'emblée parce que la personne
elle même et parfois dans le déni donc
c'est pas quelque chose de facile et de
simples et il faut accompagner les
personnes mais il faut aussi accompagner
les personnes qui travaillent autour de
cette personne parce que si on n'informe
pas le l'environnement professionnel une
insertion de risque de ne pas être
totalement réussie handicap si je sais
que celui à tout ce qui est un peu
trouble tout agen toxicologiques liés à
des à des chocs ou bien à une maladie
psychique pascal handicap psychique et
mental très bien merci nadine mon besoin
de nous avoir parlé donc effectivement
de ce qu'on fait ici en martinique pour
améliorer donc l'insertion et le
maintien de l'emploi des personnes
touchées par un handicap notamment dans
la fonction publique merci bonne journée
merci monsieur carouge de m'avoir invité
au revoir